is there ever a case where you'd
recommend that someone do baby step 2
before baby step 1 jack on twitter baby
step 1 is to say $4,000 in the bank baby
step 2
is pay off all of your debt except your
home listing your debts smallest to
largest Jack when I first started
teaching Financial Peace University
that's what I did there was no baby
steps when I first started I just said
get your butt out of that because the
fastest you're faster you're out of debt
the faster you built wealth get after it
gut it out but I kept having people in
Financial Peace University have little
things happen $322 alternator goes out
in their car they blow a tire it costs a
hundred bucks the kid gets sick and it's
a hundred bucks to go to the clinic
little stuff happen little emergencies
happen while people were broken trying
to get out of debt and and they're gonna
fix their car I mean they're gonna put
fix the alternator they're going to put
the tire on the car they're going to pay
the clinic take their kid right there
they're going to do the Emergencies
legitimate small emergencies and when
they did those they emotionally couldn't
recover and get started again on the
debt snowball believe it or not what the
$1,000 actually does as your baby step
one more than actually giving you a real
financial pad between you and bad luck
bad problems bad Murphy while you're
getting out of debt is more than gives
you a little bit of emotional margin
because thousand others doesn't cover
that many things I mean if your
transmission goes out that's 2,500 right
you're caught if your engine blows up in
your car that's three thousand minimum
you know that kind of stuffs I mean
thousand dollars doesn't cover that if
you get laid off work you know it's it's
what I mean how much does $1,000 cover
not much so it just covers the little
stuff that happens while you're learning
the budget at the first start of your
financial peace program as you just
start you know the nine weeks of courses
right then only course and you start
going to the lessons and you know you're
doing the Total Money Makeover book and
you're really doing your every dollar
budget and as
get started doing that I don't want
little things to knock you off your the
track you're on to change your life and
that's what $1,000 does it really from a
practical mathematical level is not
enough obviously it's not enough we
didn't intend for it to be enough we
want you to get out of debt but we did
put that one little bit of savings in
there because it keeps people it keeps
folks on track if they can fix their
alternator stop their debt snowball a
minute put their thousand I put their
$300 back in there so I got $1,000 in
there again and I got a little bit of
pad between me and life and I'll tell
you what else it does jack you and
believe the number of times I have had
people come to me after a financial
piece class with tears in their eyes and
say I work hard I make good money I have
never had $1,000 for 10 years all my
money comes in all my money goes out for
seven years for 14 years all my money
comes in I've just been paying bills
I've been a rat in a wheel and finally I
have $1,000 in my hand that is mine and
and you'd be amazed these are people
sometimes with a master's degree and
they're standing there with tears
running down their face going I have a
thousand dollars and what does that mean
that means that they they have a sense
that they're winning with money for the
first time why because they're winning
with money for the first time it is
truly a baby step but it shows you that
you're getting traction it shows you I
can do this it's L it tells you I think
I think this is going to work I believe
we can do this and there's so much
encouragement comes from that one little
act of in the first month most people do
it if they don't have any money at all
in the first month they can usually with
a garage sale an extra job and
scratching the nickels out of the couch
can come up with a thousand dollars and
get their their plans started and they
go WOW for the first time ever I have
$1,000 sitting here I'm not going to
touch it for anything it's just for
emergencies
but wow I really did it so there's that
encouragement as well as the emotional
margin that it gives you in case
something small happens
as well as number three you don't get
knocked off the wagon and never get back
on by something as silly as a blown tire
because you've got a way to handle that
and a process here a clear path out and
that was how the baby steps started
being developed was actually at baby
step one and two I just used to have the
death snow boss and people get out of
that get out of that you know that night
that snowball from the first time I
started because I figured that part out
early in the process but the baby steps
were not even in the first financial
peace book they were added in later
chapters as we edited and they had this
stuff the financial peace book as we
added to the course the baby steps were
not the clear path that we used in the
early days we just said hey here's a
don't buy whole life insurance get out
of debt don't lease your stupid car you
know get on a budget you know here's how
you buy real estate a 15 year mortgage
not a 30-year mortgage and you know we
were just teaching you how to handle
money like we still do in financial
piece but we weren't the clear path of
the baby steps and and I've become
militant about sticking to that you can
tell here on the air why because it's
given so many millions of families the
encouragement and therefore the power to
actually go and win and then they go win
so that that's that's why I don't put
baby step two before baby step one
because I used to make that mistake and
baby step one is valuable even though
it's very small just a thousand dollars
it's valuable for those reasons it's an
interesting thing to think about why
does this stuff work so well that we do
here because it's the law of large
numbers when you have this much data and
you've been doing it this long and help
this many people believe me the stuff
that wasn't working we've already shined
it out we've already polished it we've
already adjusted it we've already
shifted it this is not our first ride on
this cabbage truck darling